we've been asked repeatedly is this a
cult and we've been asked so many times
it I started asking are we occult you
know I mean let's be the worst kind of
cult to be leading one and not even
though it is one right and then we
started asking like geez you know how is
this not like a cult I dunno some some
of the things about cults that don't
seem to be operative here one is the
cults usually come with some kind of
crazy belief system you know like really
that really believe that here's what we
believe we believe that they're sane
William changes that you can make in
your lifestyle in terms of your exercise
that make a profound difference in your
life
profound bottom-line success I believe
comes out of doing something important
doing something significant I'm also
more than okay with that not panning out
and with the end of the day we're gonna
have no regrets because we're gonna do
the right things for the right people
for the right reasons it turns out that
it's handsomely profitable those people
that find higher purpose to business
than earning money are the ones making
all that their money